sexual arguments now without any doubt
the Creator
as a whole
that's what logic said if you want to
know what is our purpose of life is the
one who made us
for example I go back to the phone
imagine I'm the first person to make a
photo
no one made a form before me I'm the
first person to make it in order for you
to know what is the purpose of the phone
will you come to come to me because I
made it so that's why logic dictates if
you want to know about our purpose you
go back to the Creator and the Creator
taught us in this book what is our
purpose likewise before look we believe
in Jesus we believe in Moses we believe
in Abraham so all the prophets and
Messengers came to teach us what is our
purpose of life one one of our purpose
in this life is to be grateful to create
let me give you example of that analogy
imagine the house may Allah forbid
and there's a fire everywhere in your
house everywhere and you try your best
to serve yourself but you couldn't give
up and I came and saved your life
what would you say to me
would you remember me all the time
of course I saved the level so why are
you not grateful and remember to give
your life for free
you know what I understand where you're
coming from because we are too busy with
the material things
has took us away our creator it is that
even European school and college
University it's been used to brainwash
us
the wrong study but however it's been
used to brainwash us like how on the
earth try to tell us that we came from a
chimpanzee or a common ancestor doesn't
make any sense it's not even a
scientifically prove it
so what I'm saying to you you know that
you should be great to someone who takes
care of you
yeah now if you want to be you want to
buy a gift for your mother
if you give that your love or your
mother love
likewise if you want to be grateful to
you create everything is worship the way
you love that's what is Islam based upon
believe in Allah and following the
prophet Muhammad and believing the
prophet Jesus
in the stand you know you know about
entertain
yeah you know Andrew Tate he said
something like I always like to use it
because this man is a multi-millionaire
before he became Muslim he said he said
I saw the Satan with my own eyes
what did he mean by that he said that
the secret societies of secret
organizations were calling him
those who try to control us and destroy
us and he said the only religion that is
standing from against these evil people
is Islamic that's why there is a usual
against Islam No Christianity he shall
it died long time ago no Hinduism no
Buddhism that's part of the corruption
bro
you know so what we say to you that
Islam and remember one day we're going
to die from how old are you
Steamboat how many people that new age
how many people died younger than you
how many people left the house they
never come back how many people want to
sleep they never wake up that's what
Allah challenge people with death if you
claim there's no Allah then run away
from Death you know Allah there were
people before us stronger than us from
the pyramid team now we don't know how
the pyramid will do but we know Allah
mentioned the Quran Muhammad the nation
before us thousands years ago they were
stronger than us Allah destroyed them
you understand so what happened in this
life no doubt are they gonna be a slave
of your desires or a slave of your
Creator and by extension you become
slave of his desires you start doing
everything because why you just want to
fulfill your desires but if you want to
be a free person you true meaning of
freedom to become a servant to be
Creator when you are a servant to be
Creator you'll be protected should be
sheep just blind following Society
that's why the only religion that is
standing against this mentality of uh so
absolute tolerance
okay yes we can tolerate some things but
not everything bro you understand and
you know there's one thing about Islam
which is so special and I'm gonna finish
with that because I know you have to
pause
and the reason I mentioned this up to
you to know what we believe in Islam
because there's a Clear Proof sorry
proof Islam came to produce their
baskets
Islam came through their pollution what
does that mean meeting Islam paganism
atheism is forbidden because of the true
God I will demonstrate you what is the
outcome of worshiping the true God and
what is the outcome of not over
spiritual God so that's why Islam will
allow you to pray to anyone except Allah
second Islam came to preserve the
intellects that's why alcohol and drugs
forbidden thirdly Islam came to preserve
wealth
that's why gambling and interest is
forbidden
fourthly Islam came to preserve marriage
and a lineage and Heritage that's why
fornication and adultery is forbidden
lastly is of life that's why committing
suicide killing people and Justice
forbidity these five things Islam came
to preserve if we if we serve them we'll
have good Society our God is for us
can't believe destroy us fornication is
for us interests destroy us so this
vices will destroy us it's just not just
allowed within our country
evil things even though they know it
makes it's not good for us and that's
why majority of times those who are very
hostile to Islamic are those who are in
power they look at Islam as a threat for
their business understand so Islam came
from Allah Almighty to protect us
physically spiritually mentally
financially and everything you
understand most importantly religiously
yeah but all of the equal control yeah
no doubt you understand because from
religion to protect your brain from
illusion to protect your body you
understand so the the the the the the
the pointy I was going to say how Amanda
existed 1400 years ago who is able to
come with is a perfect way of life
because that man who was a messenger of
Allah the almighty and the almighty is
the creator of everything he knows what
is with us in details and what is best
for us
make sense yeah why don't you become
Muslim
does it make sense to you
are you guaranteed to leave tomorrow
you can die anytime soon
if you make sense you will create you
it's up to you
try to you know to push with something
but I would encourage you that if you
make sense to use Clear let me know like
you you know if you're a Christian you
know I'm not 100 it makes sense to
believe in God to come here and
everything so becoming a Muslim is not
should not be no problem for you you
know let me bring you back something
when I told you if I saved your life in
the fire what did you say to me what is
the one thank you girl or you don't even
know who I am I should be there the
murderer I have to be a killer but
because I saved your life
would have saved you you didn't even fix
it maybe this guy's a bad person maybe
he's better to his father we take this
shits away
foreign
when you've got
now you have a chance to become a
student she's taking a shower that
everyone were divorce because Allah
Muhammad the message of Allah step by
step why can't you from originally
you know last week someone became two
two one girl from Romania and another
guy who was from Romania and before that
one guy from Poland
you listen well man yeah
and we are here every Friday
foreign